here's a peek at what guests had to say
after the show okay we're back on the
Internet do you agree with Al Gore's
statement that Edward Snowden's leaks
were an important service I know you
don't Richard Wright President Obama
appointed me to a five-person group to
review the entire issue around Snowden
and we had all the clearances in the
world and we looked at what he leaked
and what the result was now look what he
leaked revealed some stupid [ __ ] you
know Obama has this policy of don't do
stupid [ __ ] well they were doing stupid
[ __ ] but they were NSA yes I was right
but they were also preventing terrorism
and what Snowden revealed has helped the
terrorists this is is not a theory we
have seen what the terrorists have done
they've shifted their communications
patterns we used to be able to see when
they were saying oh let's blow up the
embassy in Sana'a Yemen tomorrow right
and we'd prevent it now we don't see
that so you know I love Al Gore he
hasn't looked at then we know that's
from Snowden yeah but take don't you
it's exact same exact same very
correction post 9/11 where we went too
far in the direction of trampling on
people's liberties and that correction
was necessary I don't that was necessary
crystal but I wear oh but but he went
beyond that if you actually look at the
other stuff he revealed he revealed
things that there was no reason to
reveal and only helped people like Putin
and the terrorists know but then there's
very little specifics generally that
that people can point to well of where
lives have actually been put in so we
it's classified and I know that's a
shitty answer but it's true and and and
what's very interesting a side point
which gets lost in a lot of this is
actually the impact that it's had on
foreign service relationships for
example insurer in the UK now absolutely
again I have the voice but I have
American so I have some you know
impartiality but the the British
intelligence community is very angry
about the leaks and and for them it's
not even a question of people changing
them yeah well we're ready still kind of
pissed off about mi5 you know I mean you
had five people okay so don't talk to us
about this
well kim Philby guy Burgess who are the
others Richard Clark you know Anthony
Blunt though we did your Wayne's
historian we will come on
after World War two the leaks were in
Britain that's where it all went down uh
Robert Hanssen in the LGI much later
it's later yeah but look everybody has
spies but no spy has ever that's how
they got the atomic bomb no that's true
but no spy has everything the Rosenbergs
do has ever revealed the volume of
material that Snowden has revealed and
it's helping not just al-qaeda it's it's
helping terrorists it's helping
criminals it's helping Putin you know I
am glad that he revealed some of the
stupid [ __ ] that we were doing I am NOT
glad that we paid that price to get that
information
but on so unbalanced unbalanced or at
least nothing are you would rather him
release not if that's the choice I'll
have if I had to choose metadata and the
American people have no idea what's
going on if I had to choose between
knowing nothing and having him reveal
everything I would choose well no no the
Glenn Greenwald is on our show next week
so I'm sure we will hear the other side
of that yeah okay well the next
Republican presidential nominee supports
same-sex marriage no course not
I mean I mean well no I I think to be
honest that's probably unlikely but I
thought it's quite interesting no you
see like Rob port will come in support
you know that that there is a dynamic
though especially with younger
conservatives it's quieter there is a
actually a big is interesting talking to
you know people on Capitol Hill work for
Republican you know congressmen and
women but there is a dynamic clearly
there where younger conservatives are
you know this is not where's it where's
Rand Paul on that uh Rand Paul I think
he's he I think he's playing the middle
I don't think he's come out clearly
either side which reflects he has come
out clearly against gay marriage or at
least has said the thing about States
should decided well you know well we're
already rising majority but Rand Paul
yes we'll see if he comes but but there
is I see one of the arguments I would
make and I think conservatives have to
make is that if you're trying to appeal
to young people people who are not
voting for concerns you're talking about
immigration trying to appeal to a
broader base it's very hard to make the
argument and think
like we you know conservative have gun
ownership but then say you know the
private acts between consenting adults
is an area we should intrude it there's
a question parties how about that well
kind of investor okay okay but it is it
is an issue I think you will see I think
I suspect you'd be quite shocked how
that evolves in the years to come
years is the no I okay I mean look at
the Texas I mean they're their platform
says right up front
gays ooh I mean they're not you know
that it destroys the fabric of life
stuff this rhetoric that I thought we
left yeah forty years ago with with Bill
Bennett and Pat Buchanan and all that
culture I was a Republican Canada just
came out and said that he thought it
would be OK for game days to be stoned
to death right looked another come on
that done the fun way right yeah that's
a crazy comment though I mean that is a
crazy that that's not you know consult
again just to put things in perspective
when somebody says it here it's a crazy
outlier comment lots of countries in the
world not so much you won't say which
ones okay what do you think is the most
important thing Obama could do for our
country realistically before he leaves
office well he could do something about
immigration yeah he could there's a lot
he can do by executive order uh and he's
beginning to but it's slow you know what
I'd like him to do I would I would think
when he leaves office if he would give
an Eisenhower like speech the way
Eisenhower did about the
military-industrial complex about either
that subject or about the environment
like I'm leaving office you can't touch
me now so here's the real try wait we're
about money in politics to you why wait
is a great question one issue that's
interesting it's a
I'm really grateful si why do president
in their second term Clinton
same thing I remember it talked about
pot Clinton gave a debater Rolling Stone
right after he got out office today I
think it should be legalized and I was
like Jesus if only you're in some
position of power where you could have
done so it would have been a just just
on the issue with the environment I
think one of the things we need to get
passes its obsession with global warming
as the be-all and end-all because if you
look at my own toxicology for example
the oceans are the kind of source of
life well connected to global warm no
but it isn't but but but it is connected
in some ways but it's differentiated
than others you know entering the food
chain toxic but you know it's very
interesting that all of the activism and
their fundraising tends to be centered
on global warming and actually I think
on issues like oceans you could you know
there's an hour opportunity there to
bring Republicans into the fold now of
course you're worried about catastrophic
droughts and famines but but so but if
you exceed uux in your way remaining
ocean and right but if we can do
something you know then then let's do
that you know it's about it doesn't mean
that you have to say well Republicans
are right I mean what Republicans would
support there yeah I mean first of all
that's a pipe dream because it might
cost three jobs or three dollars for
there were three dollars so rather we
die then spend three dollars or lose
three jobs that is always their attitude
well but but well if we're gonna talk
about energy there you look at you know
Texas California in talking about the
minimum wage wealth inequality the lover
of energy jobs for people who are you
know lower skilled energy jobs writing a
lot of wealth in you know poor
communities and Democrats opposed that
if people like Tom Steyer doing a huge
amount of fundraising for excessive
regulate don't oppose it when the energy
is is sustainable energy they don't
oppose it when it's wind they don't
oppose it when it's solar they don't
oppose it when it's not hurting the
environment and you can create jobs that
way too
way more jobs that's always how we
create jobs and have giant economic
boons as with computers in the 90s it's
because there's some new fabulous
industry and we have it waiting forest
green energy but we can't embrace it
because you know too many politicians
are prisoners of the extraction
industries that's who gives them their
money did criminal charges against
Chinese hackers did criminal charges
richardclark against Chinese hackers
accomplished anything yeah it did build
it what it did was it told a lot of CEOs
in the United States but it's okay to do
what you are steel did with Alcoa did
and admit you've been hacked by the
Chinese they've stolen your intellectual
property this is causing thousands of
jobs to be lost in the United States now
we're never going to arrest those five
guys right it we did send a message but
both to the Chinese we know what you're
doing but also to American CEOs you've
got a real problem
you've got to secure your networks or
you're gonna lose more jobs right all
right Thank You panel thank you Audie
Real Time with Bill Maher
ask villainous guests your questions
right after the show at hbo.com or on
Twitter